begrüßen
aydan özoguz hat auch der
wehrbeauftragte eben noch einmal begrüßt
und weil alle infos für diesen etat der
denn es soll ein eta in rekordhöhe sein
50 3 milliarden euro sollen 2022 für den
das verteidigungsministerium
bereitgestellt werden aber natürlich
kommt nach dem 100 milliarden
sondervermögen hinzu über die
hauptsächlich der sortiert wird auch
darauf gehört die landesministerin der
verteidigung gehen christine lambrecht
präsidentin meine sehr geehrten damen
und herren es tobt ein brutaler
angriffskrieg mitten in europa es ist
ein krieg in dem russland alle alle
zivilisatorischen werte aufgegeben hat
und mit äußerster brutalität
seinen nachbarn bekämpft millionen
menschen sind auf der flucht und nur
wenige meter von hier am berliner
hauptbahnhof kommen viele davon an
vertrieben aus ihrer heimat
in der krieg herrscht die meisten von
ihnen sind frauen und kinder mit ganz
kleinem gepäck und unzählige menschen
sind ins elend gestürzt in todesangst
und gezeichnet viele menschen sterben
ein krieg und das sage ich klar mit
schweren herzens dessen heraufziehen die
ihr nicht rechtzeitig erkannt haben dem
wir vielleicht auch nicht wahrhaben
wollten und denen wir trotz dort sehr
intensiver bemühungen nicht verhindern
konnten ein krieg aber auch meine damen
und herren den wir nicht tatenlos
zusehen und auch nicht zwar nicht
tatenlos zusehen dürfen und der deshalb
auch zurecht hier in unserer
haushaltsdebatte sehr intensiv in der
diskussion ist wir haben russland mit
beispiellosen sanktionen belegt und wir
unterstützen die ukraine wo wir können
und seit dem ausbruch des krieges auch
mit der lieferung von waffen und
ausrüstung keine schwere entscheidung
keine einfache entscheidung für uns
gewesen aber wir haben sie getroffen
waffen und ausrüstung
und ich weiß dass es nicht immer ganz
groß was wird in geliefert wird das denn
geliefert wohin wird es denn geliefert
aktuell kann man wieder lesen dass
trainers geliefert werden und
es werden auch weitere waffen geliefert
werden aber meine damen und herren ich
bitte darum verständnis das sind
entscheidungen die zum eigenen
bundessicherheitsrat geheim getroffen
werden und da geht es nicht um eine
formalie sondern da geht es darum dass
immer dann wenn solche lieferungen
durchgeführt werden sie von
transporteuren durchgeführt werden und
in begleitung auch durchgeführt werden
zum schutz derjenigen die diese
transporte durchführen und deswegen
bitte ich darum abzusehen von
öffentlichen diskussionen darüber wann
was wie geliefert wird weil dann werden
diejenigen die diese lieferungen
durchführen zur zielscheibe und das
dürfen wir nicht zulassen
das dürfen wir nicht zulassen
ein auto dürfen bin ich zu lassen dass
diese transporte zurückfiel scheibe
gegebenenfalls auch vom russischen
angriffen werden denn die haben eine
aufklärung die beobachten wo welche
transporte unterwegs sind und der länder
wollen dass diese waffen dann auch
tatsächlich in der ukraine ankommt dann
dürfen wir darüber nicht so reden dass
über aufklärung das ganze dann
nachvollzogen wird
bei aller solidarität mit der ukraine
muss aber auch ganz klar sein dass die
nato dass die nato als
verteidigungsbündnis und damit auch
deutschland nicht selbst kriegspartei
werden darf und ich bin mir da sehr
einig mit nato-generalsekretär
stoltenberg unseren amerikanischen
freunden und auch bundeskanzler olaf
scholz hat es heute morgen noch einmal
mit aller deutlichkeit gesagt und ja
auch im kreise der eu
verteidigungsminister sind wir uns
darüber einig wir dürfen als bündnis
nicht kriegspartei werden
meine damen und herren diese
entsetzliche kriegszeit ob zeigt uns
allen auch dass wir in deutschland mehr
mehr für unsere eigene sicherheit und
für die sicherheit unserer verbündeten
tun müssen hier steht fest an der seite
dieser verbündeten in osteuropa denen
putin schon seit langem droht und diese
drohungen sind ernst zu nehmen unsere
verstärkte präsenz an der nato ostflanke
ist dabei ein wichtiger beitrag und wir
leisten ihn gern doch wir müssen auch in
der lage sein ihnen leisten zu können
für sicherheit die man sehen und spüren
kann brauchen wir deshalb eine deutliche
steigerung unserer leistungsfähigkeit
die bundesregierung hat aus diesem grund
entschieden
ein sondervermögen in höhe von 100
milliarden euro für die bessere
ausrüstung der bundeswehr einzurichten
und da sage ich ihnen allen jetzt stehen
wir gemeinsam in der verantwortung
dieses vorhaben auch mit aller kraft
durchzuführen und ich nehme sie alle
dafür in die verantwortung dass die
ausrüstung der bundeswehr jetzt auch
tatsächlich kommt
meine damen und herren deutschlands
einsatz für freiheit und frieden in
europa hat viele gesichter wir stehen
ein für die ordnung die uns frei und
sicher macht diplomatisch humanitär und
mit enormem engagement der
zivilgesellschaft
und deutschland schützt diese ordnung
der freiheit und des friedens aus auch
mit seinen streitkräften unserer
bundeswehr mit soldatinnen und soldaten
die in den einsatz gehen die helfen und
schützen und kämpfen die unseren
partnern und freunden seit fast 70
jahren bei stehen die ihr leben
einsetzen und die manchmal einen hohen
preis bezahlen für ihren dienst an
unserem gemeinwesen an unseren werten
und die allein durch ihre anwesenheit
oftmals zeiten deutschland ist nicht
schutzlos deutschland steht zu seinen
verbündeten deutschland lässt sich durch
militärische drohungen nicht
einschüchtern und
jetzt endlich jetzt endlich mit diesem
sondervermögen werden diese frauen und
männer der bundeswehr werden wir die mit
dem ausstatten was sie benötigen und
genau diesen auftrag zu erfüllen und ich
höre in diesen tagen oft dass das schon
ganz oft versprochen worden seid ja aber
jetzt jetzt wird auch gehandelt wir
geben unsere bundeswehr
das volle einsatzbereitschaft zurück
denn viel zu lange es gespart und
gekürzt worden das ziel uns dabei klar
vor augen eine bundeswehr die in der
lage ist die klassische aufgabe der
landes- und bündnisverteidigung
ohne einschränkung wahrzunehmen machen
und wir machen die decke die einfach
immer zu kurz war egal wie sehr man auch
an ihr zog die machen wir wieder länger
die machen wir endlich ausreichend groß
und geben damit auch den soldatinnen und
soldaten als deutliches zeichen unserer
anerkennung und unseres respekt ein
zeichen auf dass sie lange gewartet
haben und dass sie zu recht erwartet
haben und vor allen dingen das sie
verdienen meine damen und herren ich
habe in den vergangenen monaten mit sehr
vielen frauen und männern in unserer
bundeswehr gesprochen in liter und im
irak in jordanien an den standorten in
der ausbildung und keiner von denen will
säbelrasseln
hochrüstung oder die militarisierung
unseres lebens aber alle wollen die
richtige ausstattung die richtige
ausrüstung für ihren job und das fängt
an bei der kleidung bei der bekleidung
die zur kälte hitze und nässe passt und
das ist keine hochrüstung das ist eine
selbstverständlichkeit
es geht weiter mit schutzwesten und
gefechts helmen dieses schlimmste
verhindern wenn es drauf ankommt und das
ist keine aufrüstung dass es einfach nur
gute ausrüstung
und es geht weiter mit
modernen von geräten die auch kompatibel
sind mit unseren partnern mit
ausreichend munitionsvorräte mit
transporthubschraubern luftverteidigung
und korvetten die es erst möglich machen
den verfassungsauftrag der bundeswehr zu
erfüllen und dies dann auch nicht nur
auf dem papier geben darf sondern auch
tatsächlich vorhanden das meine damen
und herren ist keine militarisierung
dass es eine ausstattung die eine
wahrhafte demokratie braucht um ihre
bürgerinnen und bürger zu schützen um
nicht erpressbar und ein verlässlicher
bündnispartner zu sein und um
handlungsfähig zu bleiben wenn andere
uns bedrohen oder vielleicht sogar
angreifen und dafür nehmen wir jetzt
dieses 100 milliarden euro in die hand
und ich weiß das ist viel geld aber es
ist genau das geld was wir brauchen und
diesen auftrag erfüllen zu können und
ich höre oft dass
alleine reicht aber nicht sondern da
müsst ihr jetzt auch ans
beschaffungswesen raña
selbstverständlich und da gehen wir
jetzt auch an und wir sind schon die
ersten schritte gegangen es gab schon
die ersten entscheidungen im
bundeskabinett genau in diese richtung
gegangen sind und ich kann ankündigen
weitere werden folgen da werden wir
handeln da werden wir vor allen dingen
handeln ohne teure berater
meine damen und herren wir sprechen bei
der bundeswehr über unsere
parlamentsarmee und über die
streitkräfte die nur sie die nur der
deutsche bundestag in den einsatz
schicken kann aber wenn das so ist dann
müssen sie auch dafür sorgen dass die
männer und frauen dann auch entsprechend
ausgerüstet sind und da gilt es uns alle
jetzt unter zu harken und genau diese
aufgabe zu erfüllen ich freue mich dass
ich die wehrbeauftragte eva högl da an
meiner seite weise und sie hat gerade in
ihrem aktuellen bericht wieder auf
mängel hingewiesen und heute treten wir
an diese mängel zu beheben meine damen
und herren und ich erwarte von ihnen
dass sie dieser verantwortung insgesamt
nachkommen da geht es nämlich gar nicht
darum ob ich als verteidigungsminister
in der kanzler sondern dass wir alle
gemeinsam diese entscheidung jetzt
treffen um hinter unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten zu stehen die diese
wehrhafte demokratie
verteidigen das ist unsere aufgabe und
ich bitte sie machen sie damit vielen
dank
die
bundesverteidigungsministerium christine
lambrecht hat hier unter andern das
sondervermögen bundes werden höhe von
100 milliarden euro
verteidigt dabei ging es nicht um
aufrüstung sondern um gute ausrüstung so
hat sie unter anderem argumentiert für
die union spricht nun kerstin vierecke
mitglied im verteidigungsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau ministerin sehr
geehrte damen und herren
zweifelsohne müssen wir uns als
bundestag und als gesellschaft
angesichts putins angriffskriegs in der
ukraine eingestehen wir alle haben
fehler gemacht und waren blauäugig ohne
wahrnehmung militärischer bedrohung
haben wir die lehren von adenauer brandt
und schmidt augenscheinlich vergessen
verhandlungen sollten immer vorrang
haben aber das sehen wir besonders jetzt
ohne eigene hinreichende militärische
stärke ist für ein unrechtsregime wie in
russland das nicht verhandeln weiterhin
eine option
die eigene schwäche wird von diktaturen
nicht als ausgestreckte hand verstanden
sondern als einladung
erst nach der völkerrechtswidrigen
annexion der krim und des russischen
eingreifens in der ost ukraine im jahr
2014 haben wir wieder begonnen über die
bedeutung der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung zu sprechen die
sicherheitslage hat sich bereits damals
grundlegend verändert die ukraine ist
nicht erst seit dem 24 februar diesen
jahres ein aktiver kriegsschauplatz auf
dem nato-gipfel 2014 wurde das
kontroverse zwei prozent ziel in den
vordergrund gerückt während spd
kabinettsmitglieder wie der damalige
außenminister frank walter steinmeier
die gipfelergebnisse ausdrücklich lobten
bezeichnete der spätere
parteivorsitzende martin schulz dass
zwei prozent ziel als falsch und
unsinnig bis mitte februar
2022 fand diese aussage breite
zustimmung in der spd wir als union
haben immer für eine deutliche erhöhung
des verteidigungsetats plädiert und uns
damit eindeutig zur erfüllung des 2
prozent ziels bekannt aber die dafür
notwendige steigerung des
verteidigungsetats wurde durch unseren
damaligen koalitionspartner gedeckelt
von der langjährigen bremsklotz haltung
der spd bei themen wie fortsetzungen der
nuklearen teilhabe und der bewaffnung
von drohen will ich gar nicht er
sprecher
am 27 februar die nicht zunächst den
archiven annahme erlegen dass der knoten
bei der spd endlich geplatzt sei der
bundeskanzler verkündete eine
zeitenwende in der deutschen sicherheits
und außenpolitik
fortan sollten jährlich mehr als 2
prozent des bruttoinlandsproduktes in
unsere verteidigung investiert werden
zudem sollte zusätzlich ein einmaliges
sondervermögen bundeswehr mit 100
milliarden euro eingerichtet werden aber
hat er wohl gesagt kann mehr merzen
gleichzeitig aber es hat nur wenige tage
gedauert bis die bundesregierung zurück
gerudert ist statt zwei prozent plus
sondervermögen reden wir jetzt über zwei
prozent durch sondervermögen
schauen sie doch die rede mal nach
somit bleibt es war ein wichtiges
politisches signal
aber mit scharfe abrisskante eine
bedrohungs gerechte und nachhaltige
ertüchtigung der bundeswehr zur landes-
und bündnisverteidigung wird so nicht
erreicht
zusätzlich gibt es erkennbare
bestrebungen innerhalb der ampel die
enge zweckbindung des vorgesehenen
sondervermögens aufzuweichen dem ist
entschieden entgegen zu drehen diese 100
milliarden müssen ausschließlich der
bundeswehr zur verfügung gestellt werden
und wenn der finanzminister sein ziel
sind bundeswehr zog wirksamsten armee
europas zu machen ernst meint dann darf
sich die bundesregierung keine billigen
taschenspieler tricks bedient das
sondervermögen ist als kompensation des
investitions teil deltas vergangenheit
der vergangenheit zu betrachten
auch das sondervermögen in der höhe von
100 milliarden wird nicht ausreichen um
alle vorhandenen fähigkeitslücken der
für die landes- und bündnisverteidigung
zu schließen hier bedarf es einer
langfristigen anstieges der laufenden
verteidigungsausgaben
insbesondere der rüstungs
investitionsquote auf mindestens 20
prozent
die rüstungs planung muss über die
kommenden zehn jahre und über die
legislaturperiode hinaus einen
verlässlichen korridor erhalten gemäß
des heute besprochenen entwurfs für den
einzelplan 14 wird der reguläre
verteidigungshaushalt jedoch bei rund 50
milliarden eingefroren warum
dies begründet die sorge wie es wohl mit
dem verteidigungsetat aussehen wird wenn
wir im jahr 2027 über die dann
vergangenen jahre schreiben diese 100
mio euro ausgegeben sein werden
manchmal glauben kommt zeit kommt rat
vielleicht stellt sich die
bedrohungslage wieder als geringer da
vielleicht haben wir einen boom über
höhere steuereinnahmen
vielleicht glauben sie dass fortgesetzt
höhere verteidigungsausgaben dann das
problem der nächsten regierung sagt wir
müssen jetzt die weichen für eine
langfristige stärkung der bundeswehr
stellen die finanzielle stagnation des
einzel platz 14 ist angesichts der
stärker ansteigenden inflation nicht
hinnehmbar dazu kommen steigende
betriebskosten sowie die zusätzlich zu
schaffenden planstellen seriöse planung
erfordert langfristige
finanzierungssicherheit erst dann wird
die rüstungsindustrie auch die
notwendigen kapazitäten schaffen und ein
techniker mehr einstellen diese
entwicklung wird unserer bundeswehr und
unserer wirtschaft und damit insgesamt
der wehr fähigkeit unserer gesellschaft
mit diesem regierungsentwurf verweigert
wir fordern die bundesregierung dazu auf
entsprechend der ankündigung des
bundeskanzlers zu handeln das würde
bedeuten die über erfüllung des 2
prozent zieles und ein zusätzliches im
grundgesetz verankertes zweckgebundenes
sondervermögen für die bundeswehr das
sind wir nicht nur unseren soldatinnen
und soldaten schuldig sondern auch
unseren verbündeten das wäre dann
wirklich mal ein deutliches signal
sehr geehrte frau ministerin in
interviews kunst zu tun dass es sie
überrascht habe wie schlecht es um die
bundeswehr steht ist fadenscheinig
man muss wirklich schon aktiv
weggeschaut haben um die debatte über
den zustand der bundeswehr nicht
mitbekommen zu haben das wiederum
überrascht wirklich mich dass dies einem
langjährigen kabinettsmitglied zugeht
nachdem bereits einige vorgeschobene
plattformen entscheidungen getroffen
wurden und unter anderem die beschaffung
der f-35 und der edeka eurofighter muss
aber zwingend sehr zeitnah ein dimension
übergreifender bedrohungs gerechten
gesamtansatz vorgelegt werden wie die
bestehenden fähigkeitslücken in der lvb
vor qualitativ sowie quantitativ
geschlossen werden sollen diese krise
erfordert entschlossenes und
zielgerichtetes handeln ohne
ideologische um parteipolitische
scheuklappen eine bundeswehr strukturell
vbv muss her die sauber heraus
gearbeiteten militärischen
handlungsempfehlung liegen bereits vor
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen es ist zu
befürchten dass von der angekündigten
zeitenwende lediglich eine halbherzig
umgesetzt zeitlich begrenzte erfüllung
eines bereits 2014 beschlossenen zieles
übrig bleibt
kerstin vierecke war das für die
unionsfraktion ja man muss sagen was
hier den verteidigungshaushalt anbelangt
habe es eigentlich heute morgen in der
generaldebatte nämlich am vormittag
einen schlagabtausch zur
verteidigungspolitik und der unions
fraktionschefs friedrich merz nämlich
der hat ganz klar formuliert das erste
4g nur angedeutet hat nämlich dass die
union bedingungen stellt wen sie der
einrichtung dieses sondervermögens für
die bundeswehr zustimmen würde
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen es ist nicht
anders und auch nicht an der großen
mehrheit der europäischen staaten
gescheitert gemeinsam frieden und
sicherheit über verhandlungen verträge
und vertrauen auf unserem kontinent zu
garantieren es ist wladimir putin der
als kriegsverbrecher brutal und
skrupellos unsere freundinnen in der
ukraine und auch unsere friedensordnung
fundamental angreift die müssen seiner
barbarischen ideologie völlig egal ist
wie viele unschuldige menschen in der
ukraine sterben die viele tausend der
von russischen soldaten fallen und das
sein kriegskurs auch den menschen im
eigenen land massiv schadet und wer
jetzt meint der ukrainischen regierung
die kapitulation nahe legen zu müssen
damit der kriegs terror endet der
betreibt nicht nur eine umkehr der
schuld die schlicht unerträglich ist so
als ob wladimir putin dann mit seiner
aggression aufhört als ob man ihm danach
vertrauen könnte eine solche logik sie
ist nicht einfach nur zynisch sondern
sie ist geschichtsvergessen und um
das ist mehr als ein gebot der
solidarität die ukrainerin zu
unterstützen diejenigen die vor dem
bombenhagel ihn genauso wie diejenigen
die so unfassbar tapfer gegen ihn
kämpfen dazu gehört hilfe für die
geflüchteten versorgung der verwundeten
und auch weitere waffenlieferungen wir
müssen auch alles tun um die weltweite
politische isolation des kreml regimes
zu verschärfen um weiteren noch härtere
sanktion pakete zu führen und lücken zu
schließen dazu gehört auch so schnell
wie nur irgendwie möglich und
verantwortbar die energieimporte aus
russland zu beenden und an diesen fragen
arbeiten tag für tag hier im parlament
aber vor allem auch in der
bundesregierung alle mit hochdruck und
größter entschlossenheit
gerade weil wir nicht militärisch
eingreifen können ohne einen dritten
weltkrieg in kauf zu nehmen müssen wir
alles andere um so mehr und umso
entschlossener
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dieser
krieg führt uns in aller drastischen
deutlichkeit vor augen eine kluge
realpolitik der werte sie begegnet
kriegsverbrecher nicht zaghaft weil hier
ein lukratives geschäft
sie schaut nicht aus eigener
bequemlichkeit weg bei regel brüchen bei
aggression bei gewalt eine kluge
realpolitik der werte stellt sich diesen
mit großer entschlossenheit entgegen
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen wir
werden bestehende bündnis sowie die nato
und die europäische union deutlich
stärken dass wir unsere militärischen
beiträge zur gemeinsamen landes und
bündnisverteidigung im osten schnell
erhöht haben war ein notwendiger und
gebotener schritt nicht als beitrag zur
aufrüstung und eskalation sondern zum
schutz der eigenen bürgerinnen und
unserer verbündeten
genau dazu braucht es eine gut
ausgestattete bundeswehr das fängt bei
der persönlichen ausrüstung der soldaten
an reicht aber natürlich bis zur
fähigkeit zu wirken wie bei der
flugabwehr vor diesem hintergrund hat
das kabinett ein sondervermögen zur
stärkung der landes- und
bündnisverteidigung beschlossen für die
bundeswehr und für eine moderne
sicherheitspolitik die auch fragen von
cyber und stabilisierung mitdenkt und so
schnell und entschieden wir sein wollen
wir müssen auch zugleich sorgfältig und
pragmatisch sein und ich kann die union
einige von den einladen andere
auffordern diese grundgesetzänderung
nicht aus parteitaktischen gründen zu
blockieren sondern aus staatspolitischer
verantwortung mitzutragen
aber
das zeigt sich auch in allach dieses
geld ist definitiv nicht dazu da die
bayerische wünsch-dir-was liste eines
herrn söder zu bedienen
es geht auch nicht darum abstrakt
prozentzahlen zu erfüllen oder das geld
schnellstmöglich raus zu hauen und sogar
einen nächsten rüstungs kanal zu
riskieren im gegenteil diese ampel
koalition hat schon im koalitionsvertrag
eine wende bei der beschaffungspolitik
angekündigt hin zum markt verfügbaren
seriösen schnellen lösungen die
sicherheitspolitischen prioritäten und
einem verantwortungsvollen einsatz von
ressourcen folgt zugleich müssen wir
aber besser und enger mit unseren
europäischen partnern zusammenarbeiten
uns abstimmen zusammen planen und wo
immer es geht gemeinsam die gleichen
systeme beschaffen bin in europa nun
viele staaten investieren dann darf viel
geld nicht viele nationale
einzelprojekte bedeuten sondern jeder
euro soll europäische handlungsfähigkeit
und mehr gemeinsame sicherheit stärken
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
sicherheit muss uns mehr wert sein und
sicherheit ist auch mehr als nur militär
für echte sicherheit braucht es auch
mehr humanitäre hilfe mehr
entwicklungszusammenarbeit eine stark
aufgestellte und reaktionsfähiger
diplomatie cybersicherheit zivilschutz
energie souveränität um die folgen
um die folgen dieses grausamen krieges
zu lindern und auch unsere lehren zu
ziehen damit wir das schützen und
stärken was uns lieb und teuer ist
unsere sicherheit unsere freiheit und
unsere friedensordnung vielen dank
da kann man ja mal angrenzend an das
gesagt nicht statt oder gesagt hatte wir
kommen noch mal zu friedrich merz im
unions fraktionschef der heute morgen in
der generaldebatte schon bedingungen
formuliert hat damit die union diesem
sondervermögen zustimmen kann das im
grundgesetz zu fahren kann nämlich märz
forderte ein tier krebsplan für die
angedachten produkte von 100 milliarden
euro sowie eine reform des
beschaffungswesens und die ausgaben
müssten nur für die bundeswehr seien und
für nichts anderes
michael espendiller ist das jetzt für
die afg
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube regierungskunst gründet
sich auf vorausschau und genau an dieser
fähigkeit der fähigkeit zur vorausschau
fehlte ist in der deutschen
verteidigungspolitik seit mindestens
drei jahrzehnten und nun auf einmal sind
plötzlich alle aufgewacht die regierung
rudert wild mit den armen kopflose
hektik macht sich bereits jetzt die
grünen wollen panzer kaufen wo stehen
wir also groß und hat die ukraine
angegriffen und auf europäischen boden
tobt ein krieg da fällt auf einmal
aufwuchs die bundeswehr erst garnicht
verteidigungs fähig eine damen und
herren sie hätten mal auf unsere
kollegen die letzten viereinhalb jahre
hören soll unsere verteidigungspolitik
haben das immer wieder gesagt und eine
bessere ausstattung der bundeswehr
angemahnt und jetzt sind wir in der
situation dass wir die
verteidigungsfähigkeit deutschlands
erneuern müssen mit einer regierung die
noch kurz vor beginn des ukraine kriegs
die verteidigungsausgaben sogar senken
wollte
die populistische ankündigung des 100
milliarden euro sondervermögens für die
bundeswehr durch kanzler scholz war
offenkundig auch als drohkulisse gedacht
und die risse an den verhandlungstisch
mit den ukrainer zu zwingen wirklich gut
läuft das leider gerade nicht ob wir die
deutsche verteidigungspolitik ergibt
sich aus diesem polit aktionismus jetzt
der zwang dass man in diese 100
milliarden euro rhetorik granate auf die
schnelle ein schlüssiges konzept
vorlegen muss leichter gesagt als getan
unsere fraktion begrüßt die etat
erhöhung für den einzelplan 14
und wir wären auch bereit weitere etagen
mitzutragen mit dem wir uns dem zwei
prozent ziel der nato annähern wir
müssen aber auch zwei dinge gesagt
werden punkt eins die nato muss wieder
ein reines verteidigungsbündnis werden
zum anderen wird uns eine alleinige etat
erhöhung ohne eine grundlegende
strukturreform und eine reform des
beschaffungswesens nicht weiterbringen
denn wir befürchten dass jetzt im
schnelldurchlauf gerät angeschafft wird
das eben nicht dem neuesten stand der
technik und den anforderungen der truppe
entspricht diese befürchtung teilt auch
christian mölling forschungsdirektor der
deutschen gesellschaft für auswärtige
politik der im handelsblatt die
erwartung äußerte dass für teils über
gutes material unnötig viel geld
ausgegeben werden wird und dazu passt
leider auf ein statement von
verteidigungsministerin lambrecht aus
dem handelsblatt sagte zitat wir warten
nicht ab bis alles bis ins letzte detail
aus geplant das zitat ende ja das bezog
sich auf das sofortprogramm für die
grundausstattung der truppe und dass sie
sich daran halten das finden wir auch
sehr löblich aber trotzdem das
verteidigungsministerium muss
sicherstellen dass mittel effizient
eingesetzt werden und nicht der
verschwendung tür und tor geöffnet wird
die truppe braucht nämlich noch mehr als
von geräte- und unterwäsche
zum beispiel auch kampfjets was uns
direkt zu der von ihnen geplanten
anschaffung der f-35 führt wie die
uneingeweihten wir 35 ist ein tarnkappen
mehrzweckkampfflugzeug der fünften
generation gebaut von der amerikanischen
firma lockheed martin das spannende an
dieser beschaffung ist dass die neue
bundesregierung jetzt 35 stück dieser
flugzeuge bereit stellen will obwohl die
alte regierung das eigentlich schon 2019
verworfen hatte und siehe da schon
fliegt uns ein artikel in der welt um
die ohren mit dem schönen titel schrott
liga f-35 pinter guss papier enthüllt
845 fehler beim neuen bundeswehr jet
wichtigster kritikpunkt in dem papier
ist die mangelnde zuverlässigkeit der 35
so war die für die bundeswehr geplante f
35 a im jahresdurchschnitt 2020 gerade
einmal zu 54 prozent einsatzfähig im
vergleich andere moderne kampfjets haben
eine einsatzfähigkeit von mindestens 80
prozent der 35 ist offenbar einer hand
königin aber es kommt noch besser
gekauft werden soll diese 35 für die
sogenannte nukleare teilhabe zu der wie
vertraglich verpflichtet sind das
bedeutet das dass flugzeuge im
einzelfall im ernstfall mit dem freifall
atomwaffen vom typ b-61 bestückt werden
soll nun ist es aber so dass die b35
aktuell die b61 gar nicht tragen kann
der grund ein softwarefehler der wohl
schon länger besteht und dessen behebung
auch noch jahre dauern wird selbst die
usa haben ihre bestellung wegen dieser
menge mittlerweile gekürzt und ergeben
sich jetzt ein paar sehr interessante
fragen an frau ministerin und ein herr
schulz sie wollen also ein flugzeug für
die nukleare teilhabe beschaffen aber
die von ihnen ausgewählte f-35 kann
diese nukleare teilhabe aktuell gar
nicht leisten ich frage sie haben sie
das gewusst und wenn sie es gewusst
haben warum bestellen ist es dann
überhaupt oder haben sie es nicht
gewusst dann frage ich mich warum haben
sie es nicht gewusst und natürlich ist
auch interessant die frage hat die alte
regierung das gewusst das projekt
deswegen eingestellt und ihnen hat
keiner gesagt und jetzt stehen wir da
und haben die niete im internationalen
waffen trott wichtigen bezogen ganz
ehrlich wir befürchten dass diese
bundesregierung sich mit den 100
milliarden euro sondervermögen nicht nur
auf eine ordnungspolitische gibt dass
gerade die fdp das mitmacht ist auch ein
skandal sondern auch eine nachhaltige
entwicklung unserer streitkräfte mehr
schaden als nutzen wird ein abgeordneter
aston villa gestatten sie eine frage
oder bemerkung aus der spd gern als
konzentration gleich
bei der von ihnen geplanten verankerung
dieses sondervermögen im grundgesetz da
befürchten wir auch zusätzlich dass sie
dauerhaft die schuldenbremse damit
aushebeln werden wir wissen ja wie es
unterm strich läuft ich könnte an dieser
stelle jetzt auch einiges mehr sagen
aber dazu werden wir in den beratungen
ja noch ausführlich gelegenheit haben
ich hoffe dass bis dahin noch mehr
vernunft in die reihen der regierung an
geklärt ist und bedanke mich für die
aufmerksamkeit
michael espendiller war das für die afg
fraktion sitzt er im haushaltsausschuss
wo auch dann am ende der woche dieser
einzelplan nämlich für verteidigung hin
verwiesen wird es werden ja zunächst in
erster lesung in dieser woche alle
einzelpläne sowie das gesamte
haushaltsgesetz und auch die
mittelfristige planung gewesen und dann
am freitag sozusagen in gänze dann in
die ausschüsse der haushaltsausschusses
federführend überwiesen karsten klein
sitzt für die fdp im haushaltsausschuss
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
der völkerrechtswidrigen verbrecherische
krieg den vladimir putin über die
ukraine gebracht hat hat in den letzten
wochen die zivilisierte welt enger
zusammenrücken lassen für uns freie
demokraten für die ampel insgesamt steht
der vernetzte ansatz von diplomatie
wirtschaftliche zusammenarbeit und
verteidigung bewusst im zentrum unserer
außen- und sicherheitspolitik die
letzten wochen kamen leider aufgezeigt
wer unseren frieden unsere freiheit
erhalten will der muss auch über die
fähigkeiten verfügen diese werte frieden
und freiheit zu verteidigen der muss
über ein glaubwürdiges
abschreckungspotenzial
verfügen und deshalb ist es richtig
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen dass die
ampel dass spd grüne und fdp in dieser
situation mit dem sondervermögen
bundeswehr mit 100 milliarden euro ein
klares signal für die verteidigung
unserer werte für frieden und freiheit
und an unsere partner aus senden
und ich gehe fest davon aus dass alle
demokratischen parteien in diesem haus
dieses sondervermögen auch unterstützen
werden das sondervermögen mit 100
milliarden euro plus den kernhaushalt in
denen im gesamten in dieser
legislaturperiode 200 milliarden euro
eingeplant sind diese summen ermöglichen
es dass zwei prozent ziel zu erreichen
sie ermöglichen es drohende
fähigkeitslücken zu verhindern sie
ermöglichen das bestehende
fähigkeitslücken zu schließen sie
ermöglichen es in die verteidigung der
zukunft zu investieren vor allem aber
ermöglichen sie es unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten und ich betone alle unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten mit ausrüstung
und material auf zeitgemäßem niveau
auszustatten
das sondervermögen bundeswehr ist aber
auch der zentrale schlüssel um die
planbarkeit vor allem von großen
rüstungsprojekten
sicherzustellen wir haben in der letzten
legislaturperiode ja immer wieder sehr
kurzfristige anhebungen des veritas
feststellen müssen die eben gerade nicht
wirklich zur verbesserung der bundeswehr
beigetragen haben denn im gegensatz zum
sondervermögen hat der haushaltspolitik
der union im verteidigungsministerium
eben die planbarkeit gefehlt und große
rüstungsprojekte projekte verlässlich
durchzuführen und deshalb will ich
gerade bei der starken rhetorik die
heute morgen hier von ihren fraktions-
und parteivorsitzenden herrn merz voran
getragen worden ist eines hier noch mal
feststellen die misere bei der
bundeswehr trägt einen namen und der
heißt cdu und csu sie haben 16 jahre die
kanzlerin in diesem land gestellt in dem
entscheidenden zeitpunkt 2011
kanzlerin finanzminister und
verteidigungsministerium gesetz mit
theodor von guttenberg und deshalb
tragen sie die verantwortung und deshalb
erwarten wir auch von ihnen dass sie
sich dieser verantwortung stellen werden
in den nächsten tagen und hier nicht mit
vielen worten darüber hinweg täuschen
wollen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
der union aber
frauenministerin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen die vergangenheit dann
natürlich auch gezeigt dass geld alleine
noch nicht das material auf den hof
bringt dass das geld noch nicht das
material zur truppe bringt und auch die
planbarkeit alleine ist noch nicht
ausreichend natürlich geht es auch um
die frage wie wir in zukunft den
beschossen den beschaffungsprozess
organisieren werden es geht darum
beschaffungszeiten zu verkürzen es geht
darum die qualität der beschafften
materialien ausrüstungsgüter zu erhöhen
und es geht darum den zulauf
verlässlicher zu organisieren und
deshalb frauenministerin mit grüßen wir
freien demokraten ist dass sie die
veränderungen beschleunigungen
beschaffungswesen zu einer zentralen
aufgabe in ihrer amtszeit gemacht haben
wir werden in den kommenden
wochen und monaten dann auch gemeinsam
natürlich darüber sprechen wie wir
ausschreibungen in zukunft organisieren
wollen national europäisch die ausnahme
sind die möglichkeiten des europarechts
auch ausnutzen wir werden über
schwellenwerte diskutieren sie haben ja
einen schon auch angelogen und wir
werden natürlich auch darüber sprechen
dass wir mehr marktgängige materialien
und ausrüstung bestellen starb
wünschenswerte
aber all diese maßnahmen und
veränderungen müssen natürlich letztlich
auch dazu führen dass steuermittel das
haushaltsmittel wirtschaftliche
effizienter und effektiver eingesetzt
werden als es in der vergangenheit war
und da schaue ich vor allem auch bei dem
thema nachfolge beschaffung zum beispiel
beim tornado und da müssen wir die
nutzungsdauer das ende der nutzungsdauer
einfach euren blick haben denn jedes mal
wenn wir die nutzung über die geplante
nutzungsdauer verlängern kostet das
einen großen menge geld welt die uns
dann fehlen um in moderne ausrüstung zu
investieren aber
vor ministerin wir müssen natürlich in
diesem prozess in dieser historischen
situation auch die
verteidigungsindustrie in die
verantwortung nehmen in die
verantwortung dafür nehmen dass sie dann
auch
vertragsgemäß fristgemäß und in den
vereinbarten kosten liefern aber liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wenn wir die
verteidigungsindustrie in die
verantwortung nehmen wollen müssen wir
sie auch in die lage versetzen dieser
verantwortung auszufüllen und dann bin
ich beim thema taxonomie und beim thema
rüstungskontrolle es wäre protesten wie
auf der einen seite 100 milliarden euro
ins schaufenster stellen und dann die
finanzierung für die durchführung dieser
projekte vor allem bei der
mittelständischen deutschen
rüstungsindustrie über die taxonomie zu
machen und deshalb wie wir kolleginnen
und kollegen
um diese vorhaben finanzieren und
durchführen zu können die wir benötigen
um unsere verteidigungsfähigkeit
sicherzustellen um das sechzehnte
nachhaltigkeits ziel der un frieden
gerechtigkeit und stabile institutionen
erfüllen zu können dafür brauchen wir in
dieser historischen situation auch eine
zeitenwende beim thema taxonomie in
brüssel vielen dank für ihre
aufmerksamkeit
kassen klein war das für die fdp
fraktion im haushaltsausschuss sitzt er
die termine für die linksfraktionen eine
der haushälterin aber auch
stellvertretende fraktionsvorsitzende
gesine lötzsch hat dass sein
haus hätte ja in dieser woche besonders
gefordert die linksfraktion hat ja auch
die kleinste fraktion und deswegen sind
die haushalte auch hier mehrfach mittel
reden innerhalb dieser parlamentarischen
woche
meine sehr geehrten damen und herren der
bundeskanzler hat heute morgen gesagt
die waffen müssen schweigen dieser satz
ist richtig aber der haushalt
widerspricht dieser äußerung und das
zeige schieflage meine damen und herren
es braucht einen sofortigen
waffenstillstand in der ukraine und
putin muss die russische armee zurück
ziehen die menschen in der ukraine die
menschen überall in der welt haben das
recht in frieden zu leben
in der sondersitzung
vom 27 februar hat olaf scholz den
eindruck erweckt 100 milliarden
sondervermögen bundeswehr wehren eine
direkte reaktion auf den krieg russlands
gegen die ukraine das trifft aber nicht
zu die rüstungsprojekte stand schon
vorher im koalitionsvertrag oder sind
bereits im haushaltsausschuss von der
damaligen koalition also mit der union
gemeinsam beschlossen worden und es ist
auch ein ammenmärchen meine damen und
herren die bundeswehr sei kaputt gespart
worden olaf scholz hat in seiner
amtszeit als finanzminister für ein
aufwuchs bei der bundeswehr gesorgt und
zwar addiert
38,5 milliarden euro und allein in einer
sitzung des haushaltsausschusses vor der
sommerpause wurden waffen beschaffung
für über 20 milliarden euro bewilligt
ein vergleich die bundesregierung will
insgesamt für familie senioren frauen
und jugend in 20 22 nur 12,5 milliarden
euro ausgeben da ist ein schieflage so
geht das nicht
in dieser sitzung wurde auch fks der
nachfolger des eurofighters beschlossen
insgesamt soll dieses luft kampfsystem
100 milliarden euro kosten das
sondervermögen wird also gar nicht
ausreichen um die ganze wunschliste der
bundeswehr zu erfüllen und friedrich
merz hat die heute morgen schon deutlich
gemacht dass kam er will dass ihm das
alles nicht reicht und darum frage ich
die ampelkoalition warum lassen sie sich
von der cdu in geiselhaft nehmen haben
sie das wirklich nötig meine damen und
herren
und nicht nur wir auch der
bundesrechnungshof
aber auch die soldatinnen und soldaten
stellen berechtigt die frage wo ist denn
das ganze viel geld für die bundeswehr
geblieben wo
die antwort ist unfähigen generälen und
politikern ist die rüstungsindustrie
wichtiger als unsere sicherheit das ist
die wahrheit kollegin möglich ich habe
die uhr angehalten
gestatten sie eine frage oder bemerkung
der kollegin strack-zimmermann vielen
dank nein die antwort ist schon gegeben
im abschlussbericht einer
reformkommission unter leitung von
altbundespräsident richard von
weizsäcker aus dem jahr 2000 heißt es im
unternehmen bundeswehr müsse endlich
einen betriebswirtschaftlichen denken
und handeln neuer raum gegeben werden
das ist 22 jahre her und es hat sich
nichts geändert die bundeswehr ist zu
einer steuer geldvernichtungsmaschine
geworden und das darf nicht sein meinen
namen kann
ja die bundeswehr hat im bundestag eine
große lobby doch die lobby der
rüstungsindustrie ist noch größer es
wird nicht angeschafft was die
bundeswehr für die landesverteidigung
braucht sondern das was die
rüstungskonzerne unbedingt teuer
verkaufen wollen nur ein beispiel an dem
tag an dem der koalitionsvertrag
unterschrieben wurde stand die aktie des
rüstungsunternehmens rheinmetall bei
82,8 und 90 euro am 22 märz also 100
tage später stand sie bei 182 euro das
heißt ein wertzuwachs von 100 euro in
100 tagen das auch doch alles meine
damen und herren
im koalitionsvertrag dann auch schon die
ablösung des tornados sie kaufen jetzt
den atombombe
f-35 die faz schwärmte vom ferrari der
luftwaffe die verteidigungsministerin
lambrecht hatte vor wenigen tagen noch
versprochen dass es keine beschaffung
mit überteuerten goldrand lösungen geben
werde welch ein hohn die f35 jets sollen
15 milliarden euro kosten zum vergleich
für den gesamten sozialen wohnungsbau
hat die bundesregierung
14,5 milliarden euro in dieser
wahlperiode eingeplant dass es zu wenig
da brauchen wir mehr geld meine damen
und herren
jetzt 35 ist einen tarnkappen jet das
flugzeug kann unerkannt vom feindlichen
radar atombomben über weite strecken
transportieren können sie mir erklären
warum wir für die landesverteidigung
atomwaffen unerkannt in andere länder
fliegen müssen das sind doch ganz klar
anderes machen das lehnen wir ab das
sondervermögen ist nicht der schlüssel
zu mehr sicherheit es im kriegskredite
und das ist mit der linken nicht zu
machen vielen dank sagt gesine lötzsch
ist für die linksfraktion deren
stellvertreter fraktionsvorsitzender und
vergangene woche da gab es tatsächlich
aus dem verteidigungsministerium die
mitteilung dass die bundesregierung die
luftwaffe mit dem us tarnkappen jet f 35
ausrüsten möchte die maschinen sollen
dann schrittweise die vor mehr als 40
jahren einen tornado flotte ersetzen die
bundesverteidigungsministerium selbst
hat gesagt dass der tarnkappen präsident
auch die sogenannte nukleare teilhabe
deutschlands sichern soll das parlament
ist und nicht einer fraktion
und 1 wie sie sehen mein gehör
funktioniert auch ganz gut
punkt 2 und das gilt auch für alle unter
schaue ich jetzt in richtung der
fraktion die linke wir haben schon seit
längerem die regel auch für zwischenrufe
bleibt die maske auf der nase und auf
dem mond
3 nicht nur weil wir letzte woche dass
hier 1 geführt haben sondern weil wir
das auch in dieser woche praktiziert
haben alle präsidentinnen
glücklicherweise sind wir ja inzwischen
schon wieder zu dritt es ist nicht so
wenn eine frage oder bemerkung vom
redner oder der rednerin abgelehnt wird
dass daraus ein natürliches recht auf
eine große intervention erwächst ein
blick in die geschäftsordnung erklärt
dass die präsidentin oder präsidentinnen
diese zu lassen müssen und wir haben in
dieser woche das getan sondern haben
entsprechend der verabredung die
haushaltsdebatte hier entsprechend
geführt so dass nur noch mal erklären
weil die zeit ist ja auch ein bisschen
fortgeschritten nicht alle waren immer
die ganze zeit
nun fahren wir der debatte zum haushalt
des bundesministeriums der verteidigung
fort und das wort hat der kollege
andreas schwarz wie die spd fraktion
nach diese mahnenden ordnenden worten
der bundestagspräsident petra pau also
wenn wir jetzt für die sozialdemokratin
interesse
hätten damen und herren wir den
fernsehschirmen der französische
wirtschaft schaut politiker jean monnet
hat einmal gesagt wer einen staat
verteidigen will muss ihn verteidigungs
würdig machen werte kolleginnen und
kollegen keiner von uns hätte sich
vorstellen können dass boden tatsächlich
die ukraine
angreift und damit alle
friedensbemühungen die wir an den tag
gelegt haben ad absurdum führt und
letztendlich alle werte und regeln der
völkergemeinschaft bricht der 24 februar
2022 ist eine bruchstelle ist eine zäsur
und zeigt die friedensdividende ist
aufgebraucht das russische
bedrohungsszenario zeigt auch unsere
sicherheit ist im wandel und diese
koalition stellt sich dieser
verantwortung wir sanktionieren russland
unterstützen die ukraine und wir tun
somit das notwendige und vor allem auch
das richtige ich weiß aus vielen
gesprächen dass sehr viele menschen in
unserem land sorgen und ängste haben
angesichts dieser furchtbaren
nachrichten und bilder aus der ukraine
denn meine damen und herren unsere welt
ist nicht mehr die die wir vor dem 24
februar kanten und sie wird mit
sicherheit auch absehbar nicht mehr so
werden dennoch muss jedem aggressor klar
sein wir werden unsere freiheit unsere
werte und unsere demokratie uns von
niemandem nehmen lassen
wir werden diesen völkerrechts hof nicht
tatenlos akzeptieren und an dieser
stelle mein dank gehört ganz besonders
unseren soldatinnen und soldaten ob in
europa oder in der welt im einsatz
liebe soldatinnen und soldaten wir als
parlamentarier und die menschen im land
sind stolz auf unsere parlamentsarmee
und wir stehen hinter euch wir haben
respekt und achtung vor ihre
einsatzbereitschaft für unser land das
habt ihr auch verdient ihr setzt eure
gesundheit und leben für unsere werte
einer freiheitlich demokratischen welt
ein dafür kämpfen auch die ukrainische
truppen im gegensatz zu putins militär
das zur bekämpfung der demokratie und
freiheit missbraucht wird dennoch steht
eines fest bei aller unterstützung für
die ukraine die nato und deutschland
darf nicht kriegspartei werden
unsere bundeskanzler olaf scholz möchte
ich für seine klare und mutige rede ab
27 februar hier in diesem hause danken
so geht regieren das ist haltung
diese zeit wende braucht auch klare
botschaften erstens unsere demokratie
ist wehrhaft dieses land ist stark
zweitens deutschland ist ein
zuverlässiger bündnis partner der bereit
ist noch mehr verantwortung in europa
aber auch in der welt zu übernehmen mit
dem von ihm angekündigten sondervermögen
den hunden in höhe von 100 milliarden
euro können wir endlich die notwendigen
investitionen rüstungsvorhaben umsetzen
und dies erfolgt nicht auf kosten
anderer wichtiger themen wie bildung
sozialstaat klima etc liebe
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger
ausrüsten und nicht aufrüsten ist hier
die devise die friedensdividende ist ja
aufgebraucht deswegen ist ein aktiver
beitrag zur sicherheit im wandel
notwendig sicherheit und frieden sind
das fundament auf dem unsere zukunft
aufgebaut wird wir müssen die bundeswehr
technologisch auffrischen unsere
bundeswehr wird zu einer
leistungsfähigen und modernen armee
ausgebaut und ist damit ein
zuverlässiger kooperationspartner in
europa dazu gehören aber nicht nur
großes technisches gerät wie
kampfflugzeuge schiffe etc dazu gehört
vor allem die persönliche ausstattung
also winterfeste kleidung unterwäsche
schutzwesten nachtsichtgeräte et cetera
und da bin ich der ministerin sehr sehr
dankbar weil das hat sich ganz ganz oben
auf dem schirm
natürlich müssen wir auch das
beschaffungs und vergabewesen
schnellstens reformieren oder auch hier
nochmal meinen dank an die ministerin
sie haben schnell reagiert sie haben
schnell entschieden und gezeigt dass die
führungsqualitäten haben und dass wir
das beschaffungswesen reformieren laden
und auch sehr schnell jetzt
beschleunigen werden ich denke hier nur
an das klima unterstellen vergaben
anhebung von 1000 auf 5000 euro spart 30
prozent ca der beschaffungsvorgänge
einmal es einfacher wird ich denke aber
auch an die schnellen einkauf verfahren
unter an verwendung europäischen rechts
wir können auch ohne aufwändige
ausschreibungen in zukunft aufgrund der
nationale sicherheitslage und der
dringlichkeit beschaffen vornehmen und
ich finde es auch richtig dass wir aus
bestehenden rahmenverträgen
schnellstmöglich jetzt kontingente
abrufen und vor allen dingen markt
verfügbare produkte einkaufen daten
liebe bürgerinnen und bürger diese
bundesregierung gerade 100 tage im amt
und hatte wahrlich keine zeit für
umfangreiche einarbeitung aber wir
stellen uns den herausforderungen wir
kümmern uns um die innere und die äußere
sicherheit um den sozialen zusammenhalt
in der gesellschaft und wir nehmen die
menschen mit in diese neue zeit
sicherlich hat deutschlands einsatz für
frieden freiheit und demokratie sehr
viele facetten wir wollen eine
sicherheitsarchitektur die wird
diplomatisch wirtschaftlich politisch
humanitär aber auch mit dem großen
engagement der deutschen
zivilgesellschaft sichern unsere
bundeswehr versetzen wir in die lage die
klassische lande und bündnisverteidigung
ohne einschränkungen wahrzunehmen wenn
dieses parlament unserer bundeswehr
einen auftrag gibt dann müssen wir uns
der verantwortung und dem gewissen
stellen dass unsere soldatinnen und
soldaten mit bestens ausgebildet und
bestens ausgerüstet das land verlassen
die sicherheit ist im wandel um noch
einmal auch schamoni zurückzukommen ich
weiß dass unser staat unsere demokratie
verteidigungs würdig sind und ich bin
überzeugt dass wir ihn noch
verteidigungs würdiger machen lassen sie
uns gemeinsam dafür arbeiten dankeschön
während der bundestag
debattiert gibt es nachrichten
darüber dass
der russische präsident putin und
bundeskanzlerin
stehle phone irrt haben wegen des
ukraine krieges
das war ein gespräch sei es um die
laufenden verhandlungen zwischen
russland und der ukraine gegangen das
hat der kreml am mittwoch mitgeteilt
frau präsidentin verehrte kolleginnen
und kollegen es ist heute tag 27 des
kriegs in europa seit 27 tagen kämpfen
menschen 700 kilometer von hier
buchstäblich mit allem was sie haben um
ihre freiheit um ihre sicherheit und um
die schlichte existenz ihres landes vor
24 tagen hat bundeskanzler scholz sie
eine historische rede gehalten und die
zeitenwende beschrieben vor der wir die
wir gerade alle erleben und er hat in
seiner rede fünf
handlungsanweisungen an die
bundesregierung erteilt nummer 4
betrifft die bundeswehr er will eine
fortschrittliche moderne professionelle
armee die uns zuverlässig schützt und
meine damen und herren für dieses ziel
hat er die große unterstützung von cdu
und csu
aber meine sehr verehrten damen und
herren seit dieser zeit herrscht in der
bundeswehr eine mischung aus freude und
panik freude weil sie endlich auch von
links die anerkennung bekommt die sie
verdient von einer partei die sich im
wesentlichen in den letzten jahren
dadurch hervorgetan hat dass sie die
nicht bewaffnung von drohnen durchsetzen
wollte
panik weil sie wissen dass nur mit mehr
geld sie nicht den handlungsauftrag des
bundeskanzlers erfüllen können vom
gefreiten bis zum general weiß jeder in
der bundeswehr dass dafür die strukturen
verändert werden verändert werden müssen
am frau ministerin seit 23 tagen warten
alle in der bundeswehr auf eine große
konzeptionelle rede von ihnen sie warten
darauf dass sie erklären was zeitenwende
konkret für die bundeswehr herrscht
welche fähigkeiten sie in dieser neuen
zeit in dieser neuen lage brauchen und
wie sie dieses ganze geld eigentlich
alles vernünftig ausgeben wollen und
frau ministerin sie haben diese rede
heute am tag 23 wieder nicht gehalten
und haben damit eine große chance
verpasst
[Applaus]
es wäre so einfach gewesen als sie ins
amt gekommen sind lagen die vorschläge
auf dem tisch wieder das
einsatzbereitschaft erhöht werden kann
für die strukturen verschlankt werden
können wie die beschaffung beschleunigt
werden kann sie haben sie vom tisch
genommen das ist ihr gutes recht wenn
sie glauben dass die vorschläge der
alten ministerinnen des
generalinspekteurs falsch waren aber
frau ministerin dann sind sie in der
pflicht zumindest etwas besseres
vorzulegen denn einfach zu glauben man
kippt von oben in die bundeswehr 700 100
milliarden euro
wird alles besser ist illusorisch und es
ist unverantwortlich und
frau ministerin in dem moment als es vom
tisch gewischt haben hat ihre
staatssekretären eine neue reform
angewiesen und ich darf aus der
anweisung zitieren sie kursiert im in
der zwischenzeit im internet und es ist
schon fast bizarr sie hat geschrieben im
rahmen der bestandsaufnahme
sind laut rationale zu entwickeln an
denen optionen für mögliche strukturelle
veränderungen
ergebnisoffen zu bewerten sind auf
deutsch sie wissen nicht was sie tun im
bmvg im bmvg wird noch gerätselt was den
reit rationale überhaupt sind ich habe
das wort lüge kugelt es gibt überhaupt
gar nicht frau ministerin sie sind die
inhaberin befehls und kommandogewalt wir
haben eine situation in der in europa
krieg herrscht die soldatinnen und
soldaten erwarten von ihnen klare
ansagen keine wortneuschöpfungen
und sie erwarten für und sie erwarten
diese führung aus dem
bundesverteidigungsministerium
und sie erwarten führung nicht aus dem
bundeskanzler der bundeskanzler bestimmt
die richtlinien der politik dazu gehört
bisher nicht die beschaffung von
rüstungs
und rüstungsprojekten das ändert sich
gerade
das keine gute entwicklung aber wir
nehmen das mal so hin aber eine
richtlinien entscheidung hat er
getroffen und er hat sie auch an diesem
pult hier getroffen und davon habe ich
heute von ihnen nichts gehört er hat am
februar an diesem pult gesagt wir werden
von nun an jahr für jahr mehr als zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukt in
unserer verteidigung investieren
meine damen und herren davon lese ich im
vorliegenden haushalt nichts keinen satz
keine fußnote gar nichts von frau
ministerin wenn sie der bundeswehr etwas
gutes tun wollen dann setzen sie im
kabinett durch dass dieser satz gesetz
wird das wäre der bundeswehr damit wäre
der bundeswehr viel mehr geholfen als
mit dem sondervermögen das
sondervermögen ist gut und wichtig aber
wenn das sondervermögen weg ist fällt
die bundeswehr wieder auf das alte
niveau zurück was sie schaffen müssen
ist dass der bundeswehr langfristig gut
und sicher finanziert ist das ist ihre
aufgabe und ihre pflicht und
frau ministerin sie haben gesagt die
bundeswehr ist eine parlamentsarmee und
hören sie bitte auf diese bundeswehr zu
verbergen
bundeswehr als parlamentsarmee bedeutet
dass wir mit den soldaten sprechen und
dass die soldaten auf genau zuhören was
hier gesprochen wird und viele der
soldatinnen und soldaten haben die rede
der bundesaußenminister den letzten
donnerstag hier gehört und auch daraus
möchte ich zitiere zu den
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine wir tun
alles und wenn wir zaubern könnten wenn
wir mehr machen liefern könnten dann
würden wir das tun
natürlich kann die bundeswehr machen wer
waffen liefern der markt liefert im
moment mehr waffen als hier sie wollen
es nur nicht meine damen und herren die
truppenteile melden nach oben sie melden
auch an uns sie geben uns hinweise und
sie beschweren sich darüber dass sie bei
der leitung nicht durchdringen das ist
das problem und der höhepunkt der
höhepunkt war dann ihr interview im
deutschlandfunk am letzten sonntag dort
an sie geschrieben die möglichkeiten der
bundeswehr sind erschöpft das
wahrscheinlich schon mehr haben sie
schon erfasst das über das ziel
hinausgeschossen sind am dienstag dann
die kehrtwendung in der bild zeitung die
ministerin hätte gern mehr geliefert
aber der persönlich aber der kanzler
persönlich habe das verhindert und
angela merkel wäre das ein
kündigungsgrund gewesen so ein schuss
ins bundeskanzleramt
aber meine damen und herren jetzt gar
nicht das ist peinlich und es ist
eigentlich und es ärgert auch unsere
soldatinnen und soldaten
weil sie sehen dass die ukraine im krieg
sind und sie brauchen die waffen jetzt
und heute und nicht erst am tag 100 des
krieges wenn die rasur abstimmungen in
deutschland abgeschlossen sind und meine
damen und herren es ist nicht nur die
bundeswehr die auf eine große rede von
unserer ministerin wartet es ist auch
die europäische öffentlichkeit
die anforderungen eine deutsche
verteidigungsministerin ist dass in
einer solchen lage aufführung in europa
nimmt und erklärt was diese zeitenwende
für die europäische
sicherheitsarchitektur mit bedeutet wie
können wir gemeinsam in europa die
einsatzfähigkeit unserer armeen
verbessern wie können wir besser
zusammenarbeiten wo viele fähigkeiten
was ist die rolle der nato und der usa
in zukunft werden nicht deutschland soll
diese rolle übernehmen frankreich ist im
wahlkampf england ist draußen frau
ministerin es kommt jetzt auf sie an und
ich möchte ihnen für ihre arbeit einen
führungs grundsatz aus der bundeswehr
mit auf den weg geben geführt wird von
vorne herzlichen dank für ihre aufsätze
ja und zum thema waffenlieferungen dann
vielleicht noch mal auch ein aktueller
stand weitere strehler luftabwehr
raketen sind nach angaben von
bundesaußenminister rinn annalena
baerbock auf dem weg in die ukraine das
hat sie heute hier im bundestag gesagt
und sagte wir sind einer der größten
waffenlieferanten dieser situation das
ist nichts was ich die ganze macht
sondern das zu tun müssen um der ukraine
zu helfen
er betreute ich hier im bistum
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin frau
ministerin vor wehrbeauftragte liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen
vor 60 jahren
1962 erschien eine historische ausgabe
des spiegel der titel war bezogen auf
die damals noch junge bundeswehr bedingt
abwehrbereit
heute haben wir eine bundeswehr auf
deren demokratische tradition als
parlamentsarmee wir stolz sein können
ich will mich dem dank des kollegen
schwarz ja ausdrücklich anschließen und
dennoch müssen wir auch heute ein
problem konstatieren bedingt
beschaffungs bereit
wir haben gewissen historischen
fortschritt heute kommt bei einer
solchen schlagzeilen nicht mehr die
polizei in die redaktionsräume nach 16
jahren in denen politiker innen von der
union das bundesministerium der
verteidigung geführt haben ist diese
bedingte ab beschaffungs bereitschaft
zur insel geworden und wir sehen ja auch
hier und heute wie großes interesse der
union an der bundeswehr ist da helfen
auch dampf plaudereien aus der csu
die bundeswehr wurde auf verschleiß
gefahren und wir alle wissen das kann
eine weile gut gehen aber die
folgekosten sind deutlich höheren seit
dem weißbuch 2016 und dem
fähigkeitsprofil der bundeswehr 2018
liegen die investitions defizite auf den
tisch es wurden enorme zusagen auf dem
gebiet der verteidigungspolitik gemacht
und große ansprüche formuliert aber die
bundeswehr braucht jetzt nicht nur
bremsscheiben und zündkerzen wir
brauchen für die sicherstellung unserer
bündnis und verteidigungsfähigkeit eine
generalsanierung
die ampel
die angelegt mit dem sondervermögen ein
sanierungskonzept vor allerdings sind
fehlende finanzmittel nicht das einzige
problem denn alles geld der welt hilft
nichts wenn es nicht effizient
eingesetzt wird das haben wir ja in den
letzten jahren gesehen mit deutlich
höheren etat ansetzen als in der
vergangenheit deshalb müssen wir im
blick behalten worum es geht wir wollen
die bundeswehr mit dem material
ausstatten dass sie für die erfüllung
ihrer aufträge und anforderungen
benötigt innerhalb der verpflichtungen
gegenüber nato eu und un das
beschaffungswesen steht in der
öffentlichkeit zu recht in der kritik
das material kommt zu spät ist zu teuer
oder wird mit mängeln ausgeliefert die
beispiele sind leider legion
transportflugzeug a400m der
schützenpanzer puma oder leider ganz
aktuell die beiden tankschiffe die
angeschafft werden sollen wir zahlen zu
viel für zu wenig
[Applaus]
und damit muss definitiv schluss sein
wenn wir jetzt 100 milliarden euro für
die stärkung der bündnis und
verteidigungsfähigkeit zur verfügung
stellen was können wir tun wir müssen
wissen was wir bestellen wollen wir
müssen vermeiden dass es in der
realisierungsphase von projekten zu
änderungen der anforderungen kommt da
änderungen in der regel zur um
kostensteigerungen
führen es muss neben der priorisierung
geklärt werden ob es lösungen von der
stange gibt also standard produkte die
nicht nur billiger sondern meistens auch
zuverlässiger sind und die wir gemeinsam
mit unseren europäischen partnern
beschaffen können
finanzermittler für die projekte die aus
dem sondervermögen finanziert werden
sind so auszugestalten dass keine
gegenseitige deckungs fähigkeiten mehr
besteht durch die über jährlich kite des
ansatzes besteht kein anlass dafür wir
brauchen zudem für jedes vorhaben eine
budget obergrenze
es darf keinen freibrief für die
industrie geben überhöhte preise
aufrufen zu können
und wir müssen natürlich die
parlamentarische kontrolle sicherstellen
das beschaffungsamt und koblenz ist eine
riesen behörde mit über 6.000 800
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeitern bisher
plant die behörde eine vielzahl größerer
projekte ohne zu wissen welche überhaupt
eine chance auf realisierung haben wir
müssen aussichtslose projekte beenden
damit werden unnötige ressourcen
und die erwartung ministerium das für
die jetzt zu finanzierenden großen
projekte auch eine reform der strukturen
angegangen wird die ankündigung einer
task force ist mir dazu wenig taskforce
das hatten wir in der vergangenheit
schon genug es muss jetzt konkret werden
[Applaus]
was darf liebe kolleginnen und kollegen
in der beschaffung nicht mehr um
wahlkreis interessen gehen es geht um
notwendigkeiten für unsere bundeswehr
wenn das parlament sondern
einen gefährlichen auftrag gibt dann
sind unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
bestmöglich zu schützen
und unsere aufgabe als
parlamentarierinnen und parlamentarier
ist dass das geld der steuerzahlerinnen
und steuerzahler
effektiv und effizient auszugeben lassen
sie uns das gemeinsam tun herzlichen
dank
[Applaus]
das wort hat der abgeordnete rüdiger
lucassen für die auf die produktion
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin sehr geehrte kollegen
niemand mag rechthaber deswegen
verzichte ich auch darauf zu wiederholen
was die afg seit über vier jahren in
jeder haushaltsdebatte gefordert hat
entscheidend ist der groschen scheint
jetzt auch bei der regierung gefallen zu
sein
mit ausnahme
mit ausnahme weniger links pazifisten
sind sich in diesem haus alle einig
deutschland
braucht eine einsatzbereite bundeswehr
und die 100 milliarden finanzierung ist
der notwendige startschuss dafür um die
mittel aber auch richtig einzusetzen
muss die bundesregierung jetzt die
reform des beschaffungswesens angehen
tut sie das nicht werden die fehlenden
waffensysteme nicht schnell genug in der
truppe ankommen die afg fordert deshalb
und achtung lösung die afg fordert
deshalb die aufhebung der trennung von
87 a und b grundgesetz damit würde die
truppe endlich unmittelbar an der
bedarfsdeckung
beteiligt werden zudem fordert
zudem fordert die afd die reaktivierung
der wehrpflicht jetzt erst recht denn
mehr waffensysteme brauchen auch mehr
soldaten eine
zweckentfremdung der mittel darf es
hingegen nicht geben wie er sagen klar
die bundeswehr zuerst sehr geehrte
kollegen fast jeder von ihnen spricht
immer von der persönlichen ausstattung
unserer soldaten wenn es um ausrüstung
geht das ist für deutsche
verteidigungspolitiker offenbar ein
beliebter ausweg um den wählern die
brutale zumutung eines land kriegs zu
erstarrt erspare persönliche ausstattung
klingt nach mütterlicher fürsorge
mit socken und warmen jacken aber wir
reden hier über waffensysteme die unser
land in die lage versetzen eine invasion
wie sie gerade 1000 kilometer von uns
entfernt
stattfindet aufzuhalten dafür reichen
keine schutzwesten dafür braucht es
überlegenen feuerkraft an land in der
luft und zur see die aufrichtung
die ausrichtung von deutschlands
streitkräften braucht auch das richtige
presse personal die presse zweifel
bereits an der eignung von
verteidigungsministerin lamprecht für
diese mammutaufgabe die bild fragte
gestern kann diese ministerin krieg das
muss sie bis jetzt glücklicherweise noch
nicht können aber sie muss die größte
rüstungspolitik
offensive seit aufstellung der
bundeswehr managen und dafür ist es
zwingend erforderlich
vertrauen in den apparat vertrauen in
die soldaten zu haben die
verteidigungsministerin selbstbewusst
nicht jedes detail der umsetzung kennen
sie muss aber der
funktionsweise von
streitkräften
vertrauen und sie akzeptieren und sie
muss wissen dass soldaten eben nicht nur
einen job machen frau ministerin die
bundeswehr
die bundeswehr wenn man sie richtig
führt und ihre fähigkeiten entfalten
lässt ist ein sehr effektiver apparat
vermutlich der beste den deutschland hat
jetzt ist es die zeit diesem apparat und
unseren soldaten zu vertrauen meine
damen und herren ohne geld wird es keine
einsatzbereite bundeswehr geben aber
ohne motivation
ohne hingabe ohne festen willen
deutschland zu verteidigen
es auch keine
einsatzbereite bundeswehr gegen letzte
letzte woche sprach präsident zielinski
aus dem belagerten kiew zu uns ein
echter kriegspräsident der sein volk in
schwerster stunde führt motiviert am
leben hält ein präsident der auch sein
privileg verzichtete evakuiert zu werden
wir sehen ukrainische männer die in
scharen zu den waffen greifen um
russische panzer abzuschießen wir sehen
ukrainische frauen die zu den waffen
greifen um russische panzer abzuschießen
wir sehen ein volk das der welt zeigt
wozu
vaterlandsliebe und zusammenhalt fähig
sind können wir deutsche dass auch eine
umfrage eine umfrage der im sack gehabt
dass nur drei von zehn deutschen willens
sind unser land zu verteidigen wenn das
stimmt hat deutschland ein problem das
nicht mit geld zu beheben ist um in
zukunft das zu schaffen was die tapferen
ukraine jetzt leisten muss jeder
abgelehnte dass er es mit deutschlands
wehrhaftigkeit ernst meint an einer
geistig-moralischen wende an unserem
land für unser land mit arbeiten der
überfall auf die ukraine ist der letzte
warnschuss nehmen sie ihn bitte ernst
rüdiger lucassen war das für die
fdp-fraktion erster
verteidigungspolitische sprecher
dr markus ferber hat für die fdp
fraktion muss wird
sehr geehrte frau präsidentin liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen meine damen und
herren in den vergangenen wochen mussten
wir alle schmerzlich erleben dass
frieden auch in europa keine
selbstverständlichkeit ist putin ist ein
eiskalter das boot er schreckt auch
nicht davor zurück kinderkrankenhäuser
in schutt und asche zu legen der
unverhohlene einmarsch in die ukraine
zeigt dass dieser diktator dass wir
diesen angriff ohne wenn und aber
verurteilen müssen wir haben konsequente
maßnahmen rasch vergriffen gemeinsam mit
unseren partnern und verbündeten
dabei können sanktionen aber eben nur
der anfang sein um uns diesen aggressor
in den weg zu stellen eine antwort auf
dieses militärische invasion muss eben
auch entschlossenes handeln seien ohne
deutsche sonderwege die westliche
unentschlossenheit wurde seit dem
einmarsch in georgien 2008 und auch bei
der eroberung der krim 2014 von russland
schamlos ausgenutzt sie wurde als das
wahrgenommen was sie ist schwäche und
wegen dieser schwäche haben wir heute
eine vollkommen neue sicherheitslage
deswegen diskutieren wir heute
zusätzliche investitionen in
verteidigung meine damen und herren ich
bin finanzminister lindner sehr dankbar
dass er nun ein sondervermögen von 100
milliarden angekündigt hat und auf den
weg gebracht hat dieses geld ist
dringend nötig um den investitionsstau
aufzulösen den die union bei der
bundeswehr hinterlassen hat wir werden
wir werden endlich die nato zu zu denen
sich deutschland verpflichtet hat auch
umsetzen wir haben dieses ziele selbst
unterschrieben und wir werden zwei
prozent des bruttoinlandsprodukts für
verteidigung
unterschreiben umsetzen wir haben 100
milliarden jetzt auf den weg gebracht
oder wir bringen sie auf den weg und wir
setzen damit ein signal wir setzen damit
ein signal dass deutschland seine
verpflichtungen und bündnis wieder ernst
nimmt ich bin sehr froh dass wir das mit
so breiten rücken halt bekommen dass
außer der linkspartei tatsächlich alle
zustimmen meine damen und herren wir
setzen unsere sicherheitspolitik
sicherheitspolitischen prioritäten neu
wir haben uns ja lange über
auslandseinsätze in mali in afghanistan
unterhalten es geht jetzt um
bündnisverteidigung es geht jetzt um
landesverteidigung und wir können uns
hier nicht länger hinter den usa
verstecken
europa braucht eigene kapazitäten bei
der verteidigung deutschland braucht
eigene kapazitäten bei der verteidigung
wir haben hier eine eigene ersten
wichtigen schritt gemacht wirtschaft ein
35 35 a tank hatten setzt damit
deutschland die nukleare teilhabe in der
nato fortsetzen kann das ist wichtig wir
beschaffen zusätzlich 15 eurofighter um
den elektronischen kampf auch in der
luft zuführen das ist auch wichtig und
diese schritte waren über zehn jahre
überfällig deswegen bin ich so froh dass
wir sie jetzt endlich auch ergriffen
haben
nein ich glaube noch wichtiger schritt
ist munition wir brauchen munition
munition und munition werden über 20
milliarden euro in munition investieren
weil wir sind heute am tag 28 von putins
sieg in der ukraine die nato hat
eigentlich ein standard für 30 tage
munition vorzuhalten davon ist die
bundeswehr weit sehr weit entfernt
deswegen ist es jetzt notwendig dass wir
munition beschaffen damit wir ernsthaft
abschrecken können damit wir sie nicht
einsetzen müssen und ein drittes ein
drittes projekt möchte ich noch nehmen
wir sehen bei den grausamen bildern die
wir täglich in abendnachrichten sehen
dass es auch funktionieren eine
landstreitkräfte ankommt deswegen müssen
wir das deutsche heer investieren wir
brauchen eine kampf wertsteigerung beim
leopard 2 kampfpanzer wir brauchen eine
modernisierung der schützenpanzer puma
und wir brauchen mehr schützenpanzer
puma und auch das müssen wir jetzt
schnell in angriff nehmen das zeigt
meine damen und herren es ist eine große
aufgabe es ist eine sehr große aufgabe
die bundeswehr wurde über jahre ja
jahrzehnte kaputt gespart sie wurde
krank gespart und dieses
investitionsprogramm dass wir jetzt auf
den weg bringen ist die richtige medizin
dafür damit wir die
verteidigungsfähigkeit dieser republik
wieder erhöhen
ich hab noch eine schlechte nachrichten
schluss das alles wird nicht morgen früh
vor ort sein da steht nirgendwo auf dem
hof wir werden das nicht abholen können
wenn wir neue flugzeuge panzer wollen
dann müssen die gebaut werden deswegen
ist es so wichtig dass diese koalition
sich darauf verständigt hat jetzt
produkte zu kaufen die am markt
etabliert sind die nicht entwickelt
werden müssen die bereits funktionieren
damit wir tatsächlich auch sehr schnell
etwas haben was bei der truppe ankommt
und mir die bündnissen
verteidigungsfähigkeit verbessern können
das alles was alles musste schnell gehen
das drama ist da mittel in europa ist
krieg hier sehen wir tag für tag
deswegen sage ich ihnen wir haben keine
zeit fangen wir an vielen dank sagt herr
marcus faber von der fdp fraktion ja
aber diese 100 milliarden
sondervermögen und wir müssen
tatsächlich erstmal auch auf den
parlamentarischen weg noch gebracht
werden denn das kabinett hat das war in
der vergangenen woche beschlossen auf
den weg gebracht aber in dieser
haushaltswoche der entsprechende
gesetzentwurf beziehungsweise auf die
verankerung im grundgesetz hier noch
nicht mit auf der tagesordnung
[Applaus]
frau präsidentin werte kolleginnen und
kolleginnen sehr geehrte damen und
herren
sind aktuell in einer situation die sich
vor wenigen wochen noch niemand hätte
vorstellen können sicher auch durch
fehleinschätzung jetzt haben wir krieg
in europa die
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sehen sich
einen aggressor gegenüber der nicht müde
wird völkerrecht zu brechen städte zu
bombardieren die zivilbevölkerung zu
attackieren und menschen unmenschlich
leiden zu lassen die bilder des krieges
machen tief betroffen
olaf scholz hat am 27
februar von einer zeitenwende gesprochen
dies verlangt dass auch entscheidungen
getroffen werden die sich vor einigen
wochen auch noch niemand hätte
vorstellen können wie die
waffenlieferung an die ukraine der krieg
in der ukraine hat uns gezeigt wie
fragil und unbeständig unsere
friedensordnung in europa sein kann der
krieg hat uns vor augen geführt dass wir
in europa und in der nato
zusammenstehen und gemeinsam handeln
müssen
[Applaus]
wehrbeauftragte hat im aktuellen bericht
hervorgehoben wie wichtig ist ist die
rahmenbedingungen zu schaffen damit die
bundeswehr ihre kernaufgaben der landes-
und bündnisverteidigung
ausführen kann dafür und für ihre
einsätze im rahmen des internationalen
krisenmanagements
müsse die bundeswehr so gut wie möglich
ausgestattet sein mit einer ausstattung
die zu unserer verteidigung befähigt und
ja dazu zählen auch waffen und munition
und mit einer ausstattung die dem schutz
unserer soldatinnen und soldaten dient
deswegen werden wir jetzt
deswegen werden wir jetzt und die nahe
zukunft die mängel bei personeller und
materieller ausstattung sowie bei der
infrastruktur die durch einsparungen in
über 20 jahren entstanden sind beheben
der anstieg des verteidigungsetats der
letzten jahre ist da war ein schritt in
die richtige richtung wir müssen und wir
werden mit dem angekündigten
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
noch mehr tun um die bestehenden
ausstatters lücken zu schließen
lassen sie uns heute und im weiteren
parlamentarischen verfahren debattieren
welche lösungen es gibt pro
modernisierung nötig sind und wie die
bundeswehr den außergewöhnlichen
herausforderungen und der besonderen
verpflichtung gerecht werden kann
aufgrund der neuen bedrohungslage ist
dieser haushaltsdebatte eine besondere
debatte für uns parlamentarierinnen und
parlamentarier die über den
verteidigungshaushalt entscheiden es ist
eine besondere debatte für die
bundeswehr und die soldatinnen und
soldaten denn die entscheidung wird sie
in zukunft unmittelbar betreffen und es
ist auch eine besondere debatte für mich
ganz persönlich weil es meine erste rede
als verteidigungspolitikerin im
deutschen bundestag ist ich bin selbst
nie soldaten gewesen und war beruf vor
war beruflich vorher nicht mit
auslandseinsätzen oder dem
beschaffungswesen der bundeswehr befasst
aber als volksvertreterin höre ich die
besorgnis der menschen
sorgen um die menschen in der ukraine
und sorgen dass sich der krieg weiter
ausdehnt und
ich höre gegen zu die in sicherheits-
und verteidigungsfragen erfahren sind
das sind natürlich vor allem unsere
einsatzkräfte selbst in meinem wahlkreis
liegt sowohl der fliegerhorst wunstorf
als auch die william stein kaserne im
blut messen beide habe ich bereits
besucht und dort den soldatinnen und
soldaten zu gehört an dieser stelle
herzliche grüße in die heimat und noch
einmal vielen dank für den freundlichen
empfang und die zeit die sie sich
genommen haben ich bin beeindruckt von
ihrer motivation für die aufgaben die
sie erfüllen müssen
das bild das ich mir vor ort machen
konnte es deutlich es geht es bei der
erhöhung des verteidigungsetats und beim
geplanten sondervermögen nicht um
aufrüstung das will ich an dieser stelle
noch einmal deutlich sagen es geht darum
die bundeswehr so auszurüsten dass die
einsatzfähigkeit
sichergestellt ist und
das und das ist letztlich auch ein akt
der wertschätzung für die menschen die
ihre aufgaben für uns bestmöglich
erfüllen wollen meine sehr geehrten
damen und herren
die verteidigungsministerin und viele
meiner vorredner und kollegen haben
heute schon erwähnt um welche form zb
bei der beschaffung und investitionen es
gehen könnte die ausgaben im
verteidigungsetat werden sich einbetten
in eine nationale sicherheitsstrategie
die bundeswehr soll dabei als bündnis
armee an der seite unserer partnerinnen
und partner ihren mittel- und
langfristigen beitrag leisten können
lassen sie uns beraten wie wir das
erreichen können mit umsicht und
zusammenhalt und mit verantwortung für
unsere soldatinnen und soldaten
vielen dank
rebecca scheinbar war das für die spd
fraktion
hat sie hier gesprochen
und jetzt hören wir als nächsten dresen
ingo gegen diese aus brandis er in so
geht es für die unionsfraktion ist
geht's im haushaltsausschuss
frau präsidentin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen große worte und begriffe wurden
von diesem rednerpult verkündet
staatstragend wurde von einer
zeitenwende gesprochen und der
bundeskanzler überraschte in seiner
regierungserklärung mit der ankündigung
mehr für die äußere sicherheit unseres
landes tun zu wollen der
überraschungseffekt war bei den grünen
und teilen sogar der spd größer als in
den reihen der union denn der cdu csu
war schon vor dem schrecklichen ukraine
krieg klar dass wir unsere soldatinnen
und soldaten besser ausstatten und
geplante größere rüstungsvorhaben noch
aus finanzieren müssen mir war klar und
das sage ich jetzt nicht kollegin bürger
als langjähriger verteidigungspolitiker
dass sie als haushaltspolitiker mir war
klar dass mit den 27 25 mio vorlagen die
die große koalition noch in der letzten
sitzungswoche vor der bundestagswahl
beschlossen hat viele wichtige vorhaben
zwar den eingang in den haushalt
gefunden haben aber finanziell noch
nicht abgesichert werden konnten das
wusste auch der damalige
bundesfinanzminister olaf scholz und
deshalb war klar dass egal wer dieses
land nach der wahl regiert mehr geld für
unsere bundeswehr notwendig sein würde
der zaghafte versuch der neuen
staatssekretären vdr südhoff im bmvg
genau das gegenüber dem fdp geführten
bundesfinanzministerium
einzufordern
er fuhr noch ende januar eine eiskalte
abfuhr plafond neutral sei alles aus zu
planen war die ausführung oder die
aufforderung aus dem bmf oder anders
ausgedrückt
noch ende januar wollte das ampel
kabinett keinen einzigen cent mehr für
die sicherheit deutschlands für die
bessere ausrüstung der bundeswehr
ausgeben meine damen meine
damen und herren viel zu selten werden
in diesem haus unsere hervorragenden
protokollanten und protokollanten gelobt
ich will dass heute ausdrücklich tun
denn sie haben hinter den sitzen bei der
regierungserklärung des bundeskanzlers
immer ein punkt gesetzt der
bundeshaushalt 20 22 wird einmalig mit
einem sondervermögen von 100 milliarden
ausgestattet punkt
wir werden von nun an jahr für jahr mehr
als zwei prozent des
bruttoinlandsprodukts in unsere
verteidigung investieren
also zwei unabhängig voneinander stehen
der ankündigung die auch unabhängig
verstanden werden konnten jedenfalls
scheint die
verteidigungsministerin das genau so
verstanden zu haben wie ich sie musste
allerdings schnell wieder zurückrudern
denn die ankündigung wurden nach der
regierungserklärung
umgedeutet in denen das sondervermögen
nun zur erreichung des 2 prozent zieles
herangezogen werden sollen der etat im
einzelplan 14 beläuft sich gegenwärtig
bei 50 milliarden zwei prozent des bips
wären allerdings 70 milliarden wir
sprechen also über eine jährliche
deckungslücke von rund 20 milliarden das
vorgesehene sondervermögen würde demnach
rein rechnerisch gerade einmal für fünf
jahre reichen um die bundeswehr
ausreichend zu finanzieren
das ampel kabinett hat allerdings
festgelegt den etat in den kommenden
jahren auf 50 milliarden zu decken damit
wären wir spätestens 20 27 wieder in dem
die selben dilemma wie heute nämlich
einer strukturell unterfinanzierten
bundeswehr
glaubwürdig für die ankündigung des
bundeskanzlers also nur mit einem
kontinuierlichen jährlich anwachsen
verteidigungsetat
das scheint aber in der ampel nicht
konsensfähig zu sein und nun komme ich
zu ihnen zur inhaberin der befehls und
kommandogewalt zu ihnen frau
bundesverteidigungsministerium der
soldatenberuf ist etwas ganz besonderes
und ich sagte dass herr staatssekretär
tonga ich sage das weil ich nach 32
dienstjahren in der bundeswehr in den
bundestag gewählt wurde deshalb weiß ich
dass der soldatenberuf etwas ganz
besonderes ist weil die frauen und
männer in der truppe geschworen haben
dieses land unsere demokratie mit all
ihren werten tapfer und im schlimmsten
fall auch mit ihrem leben zu verteidigen
von daher sind diese männer und frauen
auch etwas sensibler wie man mit ihnen
umgeht und welche verlautbarung von der
spitze des bmvbs geäußert werden und da
ist zu hören dass sie frau ministerin
mit uniformierten fremden dass sie ein
oberleutnant nicht von einem
oberstleutnant unterscheiden können das
wird dem oberleutnant wenig stören zeigt
aber ihre haltung und macht deutlich
warum sie von einem fettnäpfchen in das
nächste stolpern
mich treibt es um wenn diese
hochmotivierte truppe mit plattitüden
überschüttet wird und nun der
hoffnungsschimmer auf bessere ausrüstung
unter den ampel koalitionären bereits
wieder zerredet wird die zahl 5000 v
lamprecht scheint ihre lieblingszahl zu
sein wobei ich die peinlichkeit mit den
5000 helmen für die ukraine nicht wieder
aufhören möchte schlimmer schlimmer ist
es allerdings wenn sie im kreis der eu
verteidigungsminister bekannt geben dass
deutschland ab 20.25 das militärische
herzstück der schnellen eingreiftruppe
bereitstellen will und sie den eindruck
erwecken dass allein deutschland 5000
soldaten und soldaten entsenden wird
auch das musste ihr haus dann wieder
korrigieren peinlichkeit schwer zu
überbieten beim thema
beschaffungsprozess wird von ihm
reflexartig verkündet dass sie diese im
bundeswehr beschaffungsamt 1 bw
optimieren wollen damit dokumentieren
sie allerdings einmal mehr ihre
unkenntnis denn eine optimierungs
kommission gab es bereits in dieser
kommission durfte nicht nur ich sondern
auch ihr jetziger parlamentarischer
staatssekretär thomas hitzler
mitarbeiten
fragen sie ihn doch nach den ergebnissen
und bringen sie die ein ändern sie die
vorschriften und gesetze verabschieden
sie sich von europaweiten ausschreibung
machen sie viel mehr gebrauch von
artikel 3 146 dem sie die wehrtechnische
industrie in die pflicht und sorgen sie
dafür dass der öffentliche auftraggeber
die bundeswehr endlich so behandelt wird
wie es ein premium kunde erwartet
meine zugegebenermaßen sehr hohe
erwartungen an die neue ministerin sind
nach etwas über 100 tagen im amt von
einem sinkt in einen sturzflug
übergegangen diesen eindruck hat man
anscheinend auch mittlerweile im
bundeskanzleramt
die zeit die zeit der besserwisserei
lieber craften klein warst du hier
erzählt das ist gerade für die liberalen
und die grünen zu ende der
gebetsmühlenartig vorgetragene vorwurf
die cdu csu hätte allein doch 16 jahre
das verteidigungsministerium geführt
verfängt schon deshalb nicht weil wir
immer so wie sie heute in ihrer ampel
auch am koalitionspartner gebunden waren
und wir leider nicht immer das
durchsetzen konnten was für die
bundeswehr wichtig und richtig gewesen
wäre
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
lassen sie uns sachlich und konzentriert
ich habe mir eine menge anhören müssen
und das müssen sie dann auch ertragen
weil der kollege ist die wahrheit es
geht nicht mehr und es geht nicht
weniger als die sicherheit und um die
freiheit unseres landes und es geht um
die bestmöglichste ausstattung unserer
bundeswehr herzlichen dank
für die fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen
hat nun die kollegin sara lee das boot
sehr geehrte präsident liebe kollegin
meine damen und herren ich habe gerade
zum kollegen gesagt ich fokussiere mich
einfach nur auf das was ich sagen will
ich glaube vieles von dem was von der
union kam kann sich ein stück weit
selbst
die haushaltsberatung in diesem jahr
sind nicht so wie in jedem anderen jahr
das zeigen viele nicht alle reden die
wir bisher gehört habe und nicht nur
beim als geplant sondern auch in der
debatte davor russlands angriff auf die
ukraine erst morgen genau vier wochen
her seitdem haben sich viele
gewissheiten des russischen präsidenten
wladimir putin ins gegenteil gewandt die
eu ist geeint die ukraine kämpft die
nato lässt sich nicht provozieren und
deutschland kümmert sich um seine
verteidigungsfähigkeit
dass die eu geeint ist ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit krisen in denen
wir durch uneinigkeit alles noch
schlimmer gemacht haben sind leider
zahlreiche diesmal ist es anders die
ukraine kämpft auch das ist keine
selbstverständlichkeit das
ungleichgewicht schienen so groß und
eindeutig dass mancher wohlfeiler
berater frühzeitig kapitulation an ried
aber die ukraine ihnen wissen wofür sie
kämpfen für ihre freiheit für ein leben
ohne repressive aggressive autokraten
für würde und unabhängigkeit
und die nato lässt sich nicht
provozieren vorüber ruhe bewahren es
angesagt das wissen alle und ich bin
dankbar für jeden tag an dem dies so
bleibt denn auch das ist leider keine
selbstverständlichkeit und die ampel
will sich um die verteidigungsfähigkeit
der bundesrepublik kümmern und ich sage
ihnen es ist gut dass hohe
militärausgaben nicht einfach so
selbstverständlich sind
es ist gut dass es kritik daran gibt es
ist gut dass wir uns rechtfertigen
müssen bürger in sagen wir wir brauchen
das geld doch woanders warum gibt die
menschheit jetzt unsummen aus für
rüstung stadt alles was wir an
finanziellen ressourcen haben in die
krisen zu stecken die schon da sind
absterben klimakrise ernährungskrise
soziale ungerechtigkeit pandemie und
penny folgen
der krieg in der ukraine ist so sinnlos
so nutzlos so dumm so falsch wie alle
anderen auch aber er ist da er ist da
und er geht auch nicht einfach wegfuhr
aller unsinn nicht nur lust und falsch
ist und wenn wir uns sorgen um den
frieden in europa machen wenn wir uns
sorgen um die sicherheit unserer
europäischen partner machen und wenn wir
uns auch sorge unsere eigene sicherheit
machen dann müssen wir auch
sicherheitspolitisch handlungsfähiger
sein als wir das heute sind
dazu braucht es auch entsprechende
ausgaben inhalte brand 14 und ein
sondervermögen von dem auch die bundes
verpressen profitiert eine bessere lage
in der bundeswehr stellt sich aber nicht
von heute auf morgen ein sie haben es ja
16 jahre nicht geschafft das gehört zur
ehrlichkeit auch dazu und zur
ehrlichkeit gehört auch dass mehr geld
allein nicht dafür sorgen wird dass wir
handlungsfähig sind man kann der mich
auch wunderbar mit steigendem budget am
bedarf vorbei planen oder durch
ineffizienten ineffizienzen dafür sorgen
dass wir viel geld wenig verteidigung
heraus kommt
der kollege brandl sagte vorhin was
jeder in der bundeswehr angeblich weist
wissen sie was jeder in der bundeswehr
weiß mit einem panzer können sie keine
cyber attacke abwehren
mit schutzweste schütze sie soldaten
aber nicht unsere kritische
infrastruktur und eine fregatte im
indopazifik macht keine diplomatie
deswegen ist es richtig und wichtig dass
wir im haushalt insgesamt der großen
internationalen verantwortung
deutschlands in der welt rechnung tragen
und das sondervermögen für das einplanen
wollen was unsere verteidigung und
wirklich bündnisfähigkeit insgesamt
verbessert und auf unser haushalt für
dieses jahr muss die vielen dimension
der herausforderung abbilden die sich
nicht zuletzt durch ein aggressives
russland ergeben dass information ist
kein kleinkram humanitäre hilfe treibt
unsere antwort auf diesen krieg
ernährungssicherheit um militärische
sicherheit ganz offensichtlich verknüpft
es braucht europäische interoperabilität
genauso wie europäische solidarität und
vor allem eine gute diplomatie die
beides organisiert
wenn es uns gelingt wesentliche
beschaffung effizient zu tätigen die
soldatinnen optimal auszubilden gut
ausgestatteten die einsätze schicken
wenn wir ab jetzt mit einem gewaltigen
blick in die welt schauen dann haben wir
die zeitenwende die wir brauchen lassen
sie uns gemeinsam dafür streiten mit
diesem haushalt einen anfang machen
sagt hier sara nanni hierfür die grünen
und auch das sondervermögen diese 100
milliarden
ihr einwurf ist doch damit begründet
dass vor allem auf druck der grünen
diese sondervermögen auch für cyber
abwehr und sie militärisch wichtigen von
partnerstadt beispielsweise genutzt
werden soll also nicht nur für die
bundeswehr in der ampelkoalition finden
dazu übrigens gerade heute diverse
gespräche statt unter anderem mit
bundeskanzler scholz christine lambrecht
und auch dem generalinspekteur der
bundeswehr eberhard zorn
als vor 30 jahren ein alter mann mein
großvater und ein anderer alter mann der
als
zwangsarbeiter auf dem hof arbeiten
mussten sich in den armen lagen sich
sagten jetzt ist frieden in diesem land
jetzt ist frieden in europa war ich der
meinung auch und ich war es auch seitdem
weil ich saß vor mir das war ein willy
brandt in form von zwei alten männern
die sagten was in europa frieden
bedeutet was es ist mit welcher
erfahrung
seit wenigen tagen ist diesem eine
illusion zerstören sie ist nämlich
zerstört worden und diese systematische
zerstörung auch meine pension und des
ganzen landes der ukraine ich seit
spätestens 2014 vorbereitet worden und
viele die diesen prozess beobachtet und
gesehen haben und ich sehe mich noch als
ich in den bundestag kam bei dem
russischen botschafter sitzen der mir
sagte in sotschi ist unsere nationale
identität von dem wissen zerstört worden
und dann gesagt das ist eine gefährliche
aussage weil sie hat eine konsequenz die
wir jetzt sehen in dem was russland
getan hat und was russland gerade in der
ukraine an richtet nämlich mit einem
neonazi realistischen ansatz mit einem
völkischen ansatz ein bruder volk zu
vernichten ohne rücksicht auf verluste
und auch ohne rücksicht auf die eigenen
menschen weil die soldatinnen soldaten
etat verheizt werden das sind nämlich
alles russen die der verheizt wird und
sie werden von putin in den tod
geschickt ohne rücksicht auf verluste
mit einem solchen menschen kann man kann
verträge machen mit einem solchen
menschen an der solchen system kann auch
kann die struktur gestaltet zukunft
sollten sondern wir werden uns so
vorbereiten müssen uns eben darauf zu
warten dass das was dort passiert auch
noch andere länder in europa
überschwappt wenn ich an die georgier
denkt die große sorgen haben die mir
sagen bin im jahre 2008 nicht im
mittelmeer ein träger verband der usa
gelegen hätte hätten die großen
flächenbrand
keine neue erkenntnis mit dem bis heute
zu tun an unsere soldatinnen soldaten
den ruckler in der slowakei an und
stellen gerade ihren dienst für unser
land um ihren leiter führt nämlich in
treue dafür zu sorgen dass wir in freie
doch leben können die wissen sehr genau
um was es da geht und sie tragen diese
verantwortung in vollem bewusstsein was
ihr beruf für sie bedeutet und sie
erwarten von uns hier an der debatte die
dem auch gerecht wird und da liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen habe ich
ernsthafte zweifel
kollege brandl
wenn sie sagen sie fordern
verteidigungsminister hinauf führen sie
doch von vorne ihre
verteidigungsministerin frau von der
leyen sehe ich noch bei der bildung
eines eines eine arbeitskreises für ein
weißbuch davon sprechen führen aus der
mitte und alle haben sich gefragt was
das bedeutet wir haben es am ende
gesehen was führung aus der flora mitte
bedeutet nämlich keine verantwortung zu
übernehmen sie nämlich anderen zu
überlassen um sich dann dient ja vom hof
machen zu können und dann der still sein
mehr ich glaube das brauchen wir uns an
der stelle nicht vorhalten lassen die
konsequenzen mit dem bis heute zu tun
haben eine überlastete
beschaffungsorganisation wo die leute
wirklich gute arbeiten machen aber es
fehlen in 1000 stellen die nutzung wird
ihn übertragen sie wissen nicht womit
und am ende werden sie dafür
verantwortlich gemacht dass das ein oder
andere nicht fliegt wo ihn gar nicht
geholfen worden ist aber die ursachen
die schuld zugeschoben das kann man so
nicht stehen lassen und deshalb sind wir
endlich an empfohlen dass wir mit dem
was wir jetzt haben nämlich angeklagte
und das umsetzen was sie gefordert haben
nämlich führen von vorne und zwar mit
verantwortung für das was da geschieht
was da geschieht und den bisher bin ich
dem bundeskanzler sehr dankbar dass er
genau dieses hier erklärt hat und nun
machen wir uns ans werk und die
ministerin die mindest drin die sitze
maschinenraum und zwar mit uns zusammen
um das umzusetzen
im bereich der beschaffung dass im laufe
der letzten tage alleine beschlossen
worden ist die beschleunigen um die es
da geht und da kann man ihm vorwerfen da
wird keine verantwortung wanderung im
gegenteil führung und verantwortung wird
gehört zusammen wird zusammen übernommen
und das billige spiel das sie zusammen
mit den medien im laufe der letzten tage
machen die soldatinnen soldaten sehen
das ganz genau und die sagen uns wäre
ein solches billige spiele in einer
solchen situation treibt der schwächt
die bundesrepublik der sprecher die
politische führung unternimmt den orten
rücker den sie an anderer stelle
brauchen und das bin ich
für wolfgang unheimlich war das für die
spd fraktion der sprecher für
sicherheits und verteidigungspolitik war
auch der letzte rede hier zu diesem
einzelplan durchaus scharfe töne auch
zwischen spd und union aber die
ampelkoalition bräuchte sie in tirol um
beispielsweise dieses 100 milliarden
sondervermögen es für die bundeswehr ins
grundgesetz zu verankern die gespräche
die laufen ja noch also 100 milliarden
sind noch nicht mit im haushalt
vorgesehen da gibt es ein eigenes
parlamentarisches verfahren der
einzelplan wird erst am freitag
überwiesen wie alle anderen deswegen
kommen wir gleich zum nächsten also bei
einem letzten für heute sie sehen hier
schon die zuständige ministerin für
entwicklung und wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit ist wenn ja schuld so